what is home sound like to immigrants in
Berlin an evening of diverse music from
around the world gave the highly
entertaining answer so much potential a
movie a movie a super same as American
classic photo the music of Portugal Mara
vente dance music for Mozambique a love
song from Serbia
and South Korean folk music they are all
musicians rehearsing for their big event
at the Commission oppa Berlin light till
your photo from Portugal they came to
Berlin 30 years ago to study and find
jobs they began singing thought oh in
their free time and now they give
concerts in Germany photo is traditional
Portuguese music characterized by lyrics
expressing melancholy and desire to go
boldly a publisher with you ssv I'm Finn
said it's like a window opening you
start to cry all of a sudden because of
the music sounds the singing style yeah
you say I can feel everything again
meaning it's not just the Portuguese
that many people perhaps generally more
from the South want to feel something
even if it's painful foon openness
vidual
songs from home recalling childhood
which they first learned to really
appreciate when living abroad in germany
the music is a bridge between the two
cultures
the map again from Mozambique also
learned to love music in their homeland
the band members arrived in former East
Germany their socialist brother nation
has guest workers they trained as metal
workers lathe operators and painters
during rehearsal they play songs they
used to sing nearly every evening in the
villages where they grew up now they
brought them to their new home Germany
this water kreutz shrub in tier by this
s the word coach Albans heey cross head
screwdriver was the first german word i
saw in mozambique and i was shocked and
in northen could I was sure I would
never be able to learn or pronounce this
word now i'm familiar with books by
Goethe and I'm surprised myself that I
can read them then Maggie and then I
realize I'm giving this interview in
German now so Germany has become my home
after all my name my dog of wood yeah
it's the final briefing before their big
performance at berlin's commissure oppa
the maha gang and trio photo together
with over 120 musicians from 13
countries will be presenting a part of
their culture in their new home country
it's music that's not often heard in
Germany but tonight it will take the
stage
won-ho music from Vietnam is part of
unesco's world heritage this music comes
from Serbian mountain villages music
producer yahan cooling went looking for
these musicians months of research took
into restaurants pubs and cultural
societies he was impressed by the way
the musicians were preserving their
cultural heritage especially compared to
Germans one can touch it rarely happens
that people play a song and everyone
sings along because they know it but
during this project I saw small children
spontaneously singing along if they knew
by heart the songs they were doing
rehearsed contam you die even attica
pulpwood now it's the premiere and the
commercial oppa is sold out it's a night
of musical treasures steeped in
tradition
much of it is new to the years of the
audience
so now you
but for the singers it's a piece of
their identity
then pushed him to mentioned when
certain people who make different kinds
of music come together they
automatically open up the Germans can do
it too they just have to join in a
nozzle to lose incision 1b submission a
night of international music and Germany
send an important political message but
just as important it's also an exciting
musical event
you